[Music]
that's the sound of Hong Kong residents
booing the Chinese national anthem as it
plays before a soccer match on a Tuesday
night which is an illegal act in
mainland China after more than three
months of sustained protests nobody
seems quite sure what will happen next
but the protestors we talked to on the
march to the soccer stadium were clear
that the government's formal withdrawal
of the controversial extradition bill
that sparked the protests to begin with
wouldn't be enough a lot of people have
injured the police I'm using the power
so we are not accepting it just
retracting extradition build a tree
diagram on television you thankful
William Fargo and a show called I credit
you know moving cola the protest starts
with appeal that extradition appear but
the nature of it has changed soon after
the outbreak people hope you have strong
feeling and strong emotion too when they
see the riot police try to beat the
ordinary people for of no reason so I
think that for has to be continued and
if there is no solution to agitate the
protesters say that their police force
has lost public trust and that their
government is hopelessly compromised its
leaders controlled by the Chinese
Communist Party they want an independent
investigation into the police and they
want to elect their own leaders rather
than having them selected by interest
groups that they view as beholden to
mainland China yo my vehicle Hey are
they
Leo Tonkin psycho Jojo see all the hey
yo you got a yarmulke audio clarity with
Charlie mercy Chinese government is
controlling the Hong Kong cafe the Hong
Kong government is obviously controlled
totally by the communist government so
that is something that has serviced
within these three months of protests
where we have seen Carrie Lam really
having her hands tied we have a chief
executive who is only responding to the
requests of the Beijing government
imagery of protesters holding American
flags while marching outside the US
consulate has made its way into
international press coverage and while
there weren't any stars and stripes
present at Tuesday night's March
participants did have a message for
Americans
thank you for Americans stand with Hong
Kong I hope all the American audience
could stand up also stand with Hong Kong
since now we homeowners are in a
critical moment protestors expressed
hope that the US Congress would pass the
Hong Kong human rights and democracy Act
which would make the city's bilateral
trade and travel agreements with America
contingent on China maintaining Hong
Kong's autonomy and levy sanctions
against Chinese individuals accused of
violating the rights of Hong Kong
citizens it would also instruct US
immigration officials not to punish visa
applicants who've been arrested for
participating in the protests Hong Kong
soccer team lost the match but for many
in this crowd tonight was about more
than just a game democracy is actually
affecting the future of our life like
when I grow up I will be affected by the
policies of government we just want to
have a control of our future
[Music]